the poster says it ends here I sure as
hell hope so taking three so taking
three is directed by the director of
taken two not taking one take from that
what you will and taking three someone
kills Liam Neeson's ex-wife famke
janssen they make it look like he did it
so now the cops are after him Forest
Whitaker is the cop chasing him but he
needs to go find the one or ones who did
it so the cops are chasing him and he's
chasing - who knows - who else tell most
a mystery and now we're watching the
movie alright this movie had potential
there's a world of difference between
potential in reality I always say that
but you do see potential in this movie
first of all Forest Whitaker as an actor
he's good in the movie he's like Sam
Gerard from the Fugit not as good but
he's just kind of with his character you
can totally tell when they're right in
this video yeah I wanna make Sam Gerard
from the fugitive but not really like
him but he's chasing Liam Neeson who is
ultimately dr. Richard Kimble oh my god
this movie is a shittier version of the
fugitive fugitives awesome you should
see that [ __ ] first Whitaker's acting
has nothing to do with this character I
mean he's serviceable in the movie and I
know he's a good actor and he did fine
in the movie but his characters written
to be such a cliche just roll your eyes
like a hook he's twiddling this chest
piece around because someone who's so
good at being a detective has to have a
little chest piece of the twiddles
because if a detective has a tick he is
business but that's not all he gets two
ticks and he has his rubber band he just
wraps around his wrist and does that
like thing that chicks would do in
elementary school and it was string he
does that with the rubber band you're
like whoa dude has two ticks
holy [ __ ] one tick he's a badass two
ticks he's in taken three and dr.
Richard Kim Liam Neeson in this movies
he's sneaky and he's good at what he
does and that's cool but to an
unrealistic - greed there are a couple
scenes the dude should die he should
have died like something happened
something blows up you're like Liam
Neeson's dead and doesn't show him get
out of it it just shows the next scene
he's just away from it he's alive he's
talking on the phone it was like okay I
need to do this now
you're like how'd you get from 88 son A
to B a to H doesn't show it's like what
because you can't kill god that's how we
don't need to show it you need to know
it can't happen
it's almost supernatural in this movie
it kind of takes you out of it the fact
is taken one was a cool movie
I didn't unique experience for what it
was yeah it was a kidnapping movie but
it was one of those things where these
guys who kidnapped this girl and you
just messed with the wrong family Liam
Neeson's like I'm gonna come after you
guys now they're like [ __ ] bit off more
than we can share it was cool seeing him
kick so much ass in the movie you were
also intrigued you're like alright we
need to follow the trail we need a piece
of [ __ ] together we need to get your
daughter back now takings kind of become
like the hangover movies first one was
great second one was shitty third one
not to show you the second one still
shitty any can tell the movies edited it
was like it was filmed to be rated R and
I was like no no no it's a pg-13 movie
it was like in post-production like when
it looks like yeah well screw you it's
obvious I actually timed it when Glee
Mazin actually started throwing down in
this one scene I was like okay he's
finally kicking ass yep movies been on
for over an hour he's finally kicking
ass and that the movie was boring it was
unbelievable Liam Neeson's over-the-top
badass to an unbelievable degree yeah I
suppose we badass and you can argue he
was like that in the first one I still
felt like he was mortal like when he got
out of [ __ ] he got out of it and it
showed you how he got out of it ending
tries to be all clever and convoluted
and you're like I've seen this before
and that's the problem is that taken
went from a cool unique experience to a
movie about a guy whose wife was killed
and he was framed for us and now as the
cops are chasing him he's trying to find
out the truth we've seen it a hundred
times before if you want the
quintessential experience watch the
fugitive ultimately taking three you're
not gonna remember it in t-minus one day
yep already forgot it's really funny I
gave that rating to woman in black 2 and
a couple people were like whoa I thought
you were gonna [ __ ] on the movie it's
like the second lowest reading I have
I'm saying it's a shitty movie don't
watch it don't do that price of taking 3
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more